so you should all have this diagram here
okay
we had our numbers all on this side and
then we had our numbers across the top
and from memory I think our numbers
across the top with a blue dye was that
right yeah and the green dye along the
side okay so what we did was we put the
dots here and then further than that we
said well we were playing subtractor
bingo so if you actually roll a 1 in the
1 what would you get what would the
result be
what would you cross out near to 0 and
we followed the pattern across right
you're going to get these numbers if I
keep going down you're going to get 1 0
1 and you guys already have the
completed table all right so let's pick
up now while I draw the rest of this I
will let you have some times you
actually do what I asked you to do
yesterday which is when you have all of
the outcomes laid out there which you do
it I do not have yet right you can work
out what's the probability of any of the
given scores appearing okay
what's the probability of getting a 0
what's the probability gaining one or
two or three and so on and then what I
like to do is this is a bit new I want
you to put it into a table for me okay
so the table is going to have three
columns okay the score 0 to 5 the
theoretical probability which is what
you're about to work out and then have a
think about all we've been looking at
over the past few days what do you think
the third column might be very good ok
that redeems the fact that you were slow
to get you stuff all right so we're
going to fill that out um if you recall
I wrote down lay write down those the
numbers and then different people took
over but we'll just go off my data
because I can give us numbers for these
so I want you to fill out this table
from 0 to 5 okay um I've made this
theoretical probability column I'd also
like you to put it as a percentage I'll
show you how to do that in case you're
not sure how but the reason why is as
you'll see in a second the fractions are
not very
easy to compare okay so all of these are
going to be percentages four zero one
two three four and five just round it
off to one percentage okay to the
nearest one percent in case maybe you've
missed a little bit or you can remember
how has it all these numbers will come
from okay um let's start with up here
and then everything will fall from there
636 636 what do those numbers represent
yeah fantastic one two three four five
six so in other words the top of that
fraction every time it's a probability
it's the favorable outcomes right and
there are six of them there okay good
where does the 36 come from yeah yeah
fantastic all the outcomes right you can
have all of its six by six and it's a
square so that's why we get 36 from
right now when you punch that in that's
equal to one over six and I think it's
sixteen point six six sixty-six percent
or whatever it is which I'm just
rounding off okay
so that's where I get this figure from
okay I just want percentages to make
everything easy to compare it's usually
why we have percentages right so by now
you've gotten a little way through you
should be counting the rest of these I'm
filled them all out for you but you'll
be able to tell me you know tell me what
the young percentage is on this next one
said I'm wiped out or eight twenty
twenty seven point seven which rounds up
to twenty eight doesn't it okay by the
way just as a note because we're
rounding all of these right notice that
this one rounded up and this one also
rounded up depending on how these all
round all these black percentage numbers
right here they might not add up to one
hundred percent
they met up to 99 or 100 one just
depends on the rounding okay can someone
tell me the next one
please sue okay now I haven't filled in
for the three four and five but you can
count up on the dot diagram how many
threes are there yeah that's very good
okay so you're three over here and three
of them there use the symmetry to your
advantage
6 over 36 which we've already worked out
that's going to be 17% by the way those
Wiggly equal signs they just mean
approximately it's the same as um same
as writing an equal sign with dots above
and below it but at least when I'm
writing real whiteboard my grits not so
bad but when you're doing it in pen
often the dots they're just you can't
see them so I think the wiggle it sounds
a little more obvious how many Falls are
there for very good it's kind of crisper
the top 4 out of 36 that's equal to 1/9
which I think would be 11 percent right
and that leaves us with just those two
fives on the corners yeah two out of 36
which is approximately equal to 6 which
by the way you could work out without
your calculator because you can look at
this you can say well roughly and then
you can do the rounding right there
should be 5.5 goes up so 6% excellent ok
so now you have a look at these numbers
now because this is experimental
probability these represent what I
actually rolled okay I didn't include
some pairs and Connor's because just
take me too long to work out the numbers
so I have 52 rolls in total I think that
was three rounds and then other people
took over and these were how many of
each number we actually did all right so
let's get these numbers as percentages
really quickly
10:52 19
okay 39:52 someone inside the room
someone got a ring this is an easy one
that's 10 out of 52 it's a special
number to recognize where these numbers
come from this is a common set of
numbers in probability 52 52 there are
52 weeks in a year but there are also 52
playing cards in a deck and there are
four suits each of which has 13,000 so
because there are four you know that
Tigers for that yeah yeah that's right I
had it but anyway that's that number you
ought to be on record I'm 12 out of 52
genuine
23 I'm guessing 26 so all right 27 has
it round Minister 27 and then these
numbers here are going to be very small
aren't they whoop said good which we
expecting that's five okay now I just
want you to have a look at this table
now that is complete you can see that
there are quite a few discrepancies
aren't there right some of the numbers
very very close look at this 17 verses
1928 versus 25 this one is within 1% 22
versus 23
okay but these other numbers they're
kind of thrown off aren't they because
we just happen to get a lot more threes
than we should have expected that's why
these are a lot lower than also what we
expected which is why you guys kept the
scene come on why are we getting four
fires actually we should have probably
got more for surprised that we really
got okay now I'm going to replay this
scenario again I wonder if you've still
got your sheet there and if you've used
up all of the rounds okay we can use
this to design in theory the perfect
card there are 12 spots to fill 12 okay
so being that see this column here this
one this is what is supposed to happen
it doesn't always happen but this is in
theory what should happen so on the
basis of this middle column
what would the perf
card look like I've got 12 spots to fill
okay how many for instance how many
zeros should there be in my 12 spots how
will we go about calculating it based on
that column
well we predicted 17% of our rolls
should end up with a 0 right Smith v 0
to 0 ok now where did you get the number
2 from 3 ones okay so was that but where
do you get that from those are the
numbers where do they come from
okay good so the first thing we should
say is look see what this one we predict
it should be 28% look how many ones
there are it's clearly going to be the
most common and it was no it wasn't that
was weird
okay um but we should have the most ones
but I'm not just choosing out I want the
most ones I want to know how many ones
there should be because they're not all
going to be one so let me come back to
the zeros that was the first question I
asked
I predict 17% of my roles should end up
as a zero so therefore I should predict
that 17% of my 12 will end up as zeros
right 17% of them
so what's 17 percent or 12 well it's
actually if we go back to exactly the
sixth right so it's exactly two right so
we should predict for the zeros right we
should proceed two of them okay for the
ones how many should we predict we
should be 28% right what is 20% 8% it's
not going to be a neat number rezulin
3.36
okay so that's going to round down so
I'm expecting three right but there's
still quite a decent chance that it
could go up right and you can continue
this right for two three four and five
go ahead and do that design the perfect
card tell me how many I'm going to get
for each of these numbers okay so let's
have a look at 2/5
8:12 perfect and this should be our
perfect card in theory right 0 0 1 1 1 2
2 2 3 3 4 5 that's it okay alright now
let me talk with one final question
before we end on this okay that's the
perfect card that's the ideal card but
if you have a look at the people for
anyone who want anyone who actually won
I want you to compare your winning card
I know not everyone has a win up sorry
but those of you who do sometimes more
than one will be different to this card
right your card won't match this card
that's the first thing the second thing
is this card would always win even
though it's the inverted commas the
perfect card